[Music]
welcome back to dirty arty chapter nine
in a happy new year to all of you thanks
for watching and joining us we took a
week off for the break and I am joined
here with Joey mr. Joey hello who is one
of our I think you've cut actually
almost all of the authority are I think
all but two all but two Jake did the
other ones yeah because Jake is
unfortunately out of the office so I
think you are definitely the next best
thing to replace yeah I would say if
dirty Artie I feel is more of a concept
than like an actual person yeah so it's
it's kind of like what I would I would
say like James Bond where you can have
like different people fill in the roles
of dirty Artie and by the way I know
there's actually a good number of people
in the comments that have taken dirty
Artie and use them has inspiration for
their own Rd which is really cool and I
think that if you guys have your own
version of him that you want us to see
just you know hit us up on Twitter sent
us a picture and we'll see if we can get
them and get those uh Artie's or the RTR
me Harvey in the next episode yeah
definitely I want to see him as well
show us your Ortiz show us your artis
alright we're actually where are we
right now Helen it's a good question
well yeah we're this is the I guess
we'll call it a New Year's special a
very arty new year mmm-hmm we are we
should be here on was a mountain hagen
perfect we're almost here so Joey you
kind of put together this episode in a
way you know we should have a very
festive hat in attire for a very festive
episode yeah what what is a new year
without a nice hat like a really cool
hat to go along with it so I think the
first one that we're gonna get here is
the what's called the the more more ioan
hat okay which hit I don't know how to
describe it other than it's huge
gaudy metal with feathers sticking out
of it perfect
so then after that check our map here
the plan is to go all the way down to
some
the knee and find are like what like a
nice jackets we need slacks
snazzy outfit snazzy I like that
whatever you what you would normally
bring to like the best party totally
we're gonna get that for our tea and
after that we're gonna go to strawberry
and we need some some friends to help
celebrate our tea has no friends so
definitely no friends all we can do is
kidnap people yeah so we'll kidnap some
people we'll bring them up to Mount Shan
here yeah for the countdown for the
countdown and some fireworks and we'll
probably take the liberty of using some
cheat codes to spawn in a stagecoach
ourselves and see if we can ride that
down the mountain with some time
dynamite we're gonna party like it's
1942 and it should be one hell of a
send-off in the end oh well well well oh
well what a poor soul hey get up here
fellow from a long time ago oh there
takes that Oh beautiful hello my friend
I think my favorite part is that the the
string that goes around his chin is like
going through the beard yes it's like
it's like a chin strap like legit right
like on the on the tip of your chin you
see that shiver from Rd oh my feet
perfect so now we go to sanda knee and
find a fun a nice a nice jacket
somebody it's almost it's almost like
we're doing like sorry Mardi Gras or
something that is so tall it's so
wonderful how do we get down you just go
down yeah oh look Shrek likes it yes
more more more Oh
I have a feeling we're gonna lose a
horse not doing it why did I do
why don't you do this Shrek we can
neither revive nor kill what for having
a crap horse that's why our owner went
down for leaving him in the snow like
this this is gonna go so horrible
horribly wrong I'm already having
flashbacks from was it Chapter six I
think yeah what's the nearest town
Christ he's come he's got Oh cram no
that's a that's not gonna work out hmm
at least we get to keep the Hat right
yeah how close are we oh we have a hope
so we do have more yeah this is this is
just a temporary one oh we can pick up
our old saddle too crap
I wonder if dirty already thinks like
he's living in a world like Netflix's
Bandersnatch like he's being controlled
I don't want to do this I gotta so
slowly I think I can make this lowly Wow
for a second I thought I already
switched alright the main horse you I
don't even know how many Steve's we're
at right now well I guess we're at Shrek
2 or at Shrek 2 he name is check
I mean we might as well go through the
whole trilogy alright where are we
Sanda nice Valentine's station if you
have any sand the knee tires in mine I'm
trying to remember let me go take a look
like do we want to go fancy like we have
to we'd have to get like trapper stuff
we wanted to hear right there where did
you folks meet the freakshow be smart
how do you remember us how can you be
alive vaguely remember your head being
gone I'm back here once again we won't
be causing too much trouble here right
no I don't think so
hey you say that now I mean if someone
talks on our awesome asshat yeah we're
gonna get some clothes alright so I
guess we're are we okay with shrek - I
am good with shrek - you can't and by
the way you said it was a trilogy
there's actually a fourth shrek look
there is the fourth one yeah I forgot
shrek forever after really yeah it was
originally going to be called shrek goes
forth to keep with like the I don't know
the the third fantasy theme oh wait I
like that but fix forever after it was
probably the weakest out of the Shrek
movies not counting the the holiday
specials Ellie's yep predictive text
already there so I can just number two
number two yeah dreadlocks looks
horrible so maybe we should roll with
this all right so I'll go with it
disgusting disgusting and then tail we
generally go with the braid the braid I
say we keep the braid just that'll be
the one thing that kind of connects all
of our horses Alps that green and brown
tail
yeah so gross yeah you bet all right
let's go buy some new digs okay so I'm
thinking we get at okay so I got a let's
shirt let's check out fits first and
then maybe if nothing looks good we can
customize our own basically okay let's
buy that one
oh you can't we can and then we'll
change up the shirt I think we need a
new shirt that is so ugly I like that
one that's a little a little halfsie
they're really gross
yellow yeah right yeah anyway my eyes a
little bottom is it'll get real dirty to
[Laughter]
breathe yeah let him breathe let Artie
you know let loose a little bit and he's
always got this huge coat on maybe it's
I don't know maybe hold him back a
little bit I like that and also it'll
look way better when it's covered in che
[Music]
about my vision oh this could be our
first friend oh my god you're totally
right footing there that far hello 1,300
we're fine thanks though we're okay
thanks great city great city thank you
this shot they shot him in the leg did
he die he looks kind of dead that's okay
he'll just be sleeping he looks like
what oh please don't tell me God dang it
we lost Shrek - we lost rekt - dang it
we just got ah sorry Shrek - thank you
my favorite track should i okay Trump a
guy I want that Trump a guy to come with
us we need some music you're coming with
me my friend please stop making that
racket is that guy guys are fighting
oh no oh did I did I yell at him no it
was a trumpet guy cuz he's like please
stop is this his manager Oh No
do something this isn't me just go after
the trumpet guy cuz run yeah it's good
call
will get my hat later okay a weird sense
of deja vu right now hopefully this one
doesn't get shot okay so we'll go to
strawberry we'll get up Oh she'll meet
let's go to roads well then we have to
we're gonna lose our guy then hmm
we're gonna we're gonna have some
run-ins might as well just kill him
[Laughter]
never let food go to waste near do we
strawberry please
okay so we're new here in town
strawberry mother's is it's pretty it's
pretty good yeah pretty good
second only to Valentine I think yeah
antagonize people from up here we'll
just Park it somewhere come back for it
later yeah over here
Wow can you get your horse up there
thinks wreck would wanna make that jump
or Shrek 2 Shrek the third let's check
the third let's see how this move east
oh no was this technically the third we
didn't really I guess this is one of the
Shrek spin-offs not the official
releases okay so let's let's go get our
hat and then spawn a stagecoach all we
need to get the mayor we need to bring
him with us it might be too much work to
get many people what if we I mean if we
just got the mayor that's pretty good I
think that's that's a good catch right
there right and I think we could
probably call it and then that's a party
and we'll bring them up there you
smarten yourself up a bit you're
lowering the tone oh oh I can't wait
have a New Year's with you this is a
fair town in a nice town and a proper
town and as such it's a town for fair
and nice and proper people
okay I think you can hold on now right
yes don't shoot them don't shoot the
mayor is he still I think you still
alive yeah he's moving okay that's fine
okay his arms are in a real rough
position there oh that's fine all right
I saw you I say you spawn in out the
stagecoach wagon we'll put them in the
back of that would be like as casket
just put like a stick and don't ignite
it right oh so while it's not midnight
quite yet it's about 5:30 still pregame
it right it's it's midnight somewhere
put some dynamite on this oh you can put
it on the tires yeah that's sick like a
little sparklers horse - well as close
as we can that's as close as it gets
well let's let's test out the fireworks
real quick they work
[Music]
no despond are you serious yeah I
totally know our mayor Shh well whatever
I say you just spawn another wagon put
dime on it and just ride it down
Oh bounty hunters they won a party too
oh yeah yeah yeah wait for it wait for
it do I do it happy new year shoot out
some fireworks a little early here hey
we end up dude we end up having a party
people ended up coming that's great
we thought we didn't have any friends oh
yeah we at least got one guy to join us
no don't roll don't roll down no no no
we're not party's not done don't fall
into the fire please going I think it's
about 11 o'clock Oh 10:30 10:30 oh man
we're we're getting right to the end
here perfect we had a party people left
a little early just throw throw okay
throw down right in front of you or
rolling down and then the shooter would
and then put put a dynamite light it oh
that's oh that's mom all right it's
Happy New Year
[Music]
[Applause]
drunk real quick yeah and also put a
dynamite in the back of the state of the
wagon and then ride it down Happy New
Year
[Music]
everywhere
[Music]
well great thank you all for watching
glad we ended that with a bang we
definitely did and by the way guys
remember if you have your own version of
your own dirty arty that you'd like us
to see just hit hit us up on Twitter and
send us a picture and we'll feature it
in one of the future episodes of dirty
arty so stay tuned next week for chapter
10 that's a big milestone thanks Joey
for subbing in for Jake and we'll see
you all next week
[Music]
ah